he could not have been more generous
with his time his passion
uh his retweets for his remarkable um
and regramming of his incredible social
media footprint
um and uh i i we we all thought he would
run the fastest out of all the nfl
legends for the 2021 run rich run
um and he did and i knew that people
were talking about that
after the run and they are he is michael
vick
here on the rich eisen show how are you
sir i'm doing great rich how about
yourself
you i'm i'm i couldn't be more thrilled
at how you ran
and your generosity with your time to
come all the way out to los angeles
and to give it your all to give your uh
give
of uh your time and hamstrings to st
jude
michael thank you i appreciate that
definitely gave a hamstring to think
jewel but like i said
and i reiterated it was for a good cause
and yes
rich everybody and i who was there
knew that i would run the fastest time
it's just that i thought i would run
faster
i'll leave it at that yeah and look
yeah i want to say this to the people
because i'm proud about it i'm proud
about
you know one you know it was a
successful event
and we was able to raise that money
and you know it was amazing
two everybody put the time and effort
into it man and
and uh you know three i really wanted to
run a 4-5
for the people but next year i'm a train
and hopefully you'll invite me back man
and i'll be more than glad to come back
no doubt so at what point in this run
did your your hammy give way michael uh
it was
it was i had like i think i had maybe
like 15 yards left you know what
happened rich
i'm running and the first 20 yards i got
out
even chris carter was behind me he was
like oh mike you was getting it
and and i was going to something i felt
good and then i felt that
that like it's like when a tire go flat
you know when you riding on the road you
just hear that don't don't
you hear that thump and i felt that
thump and which i've
known all too well over my years yes and
uh it was about halfway in that last 10
yards really count in terms of just kind
of like
leaning in and finishing strong but
i learned the lesson man and you know
what man i could have been with a better
group
yeah it couldn't happen at a better time
even to pull my hamstring
you know when i think about it as i limp
around the house man out here in florida
you know i'm like man you know i did it
for all the right reasons yes you did
michael and you ran with andy dunn the
uh
the donor uh who along with seven others
gave over a million dollars for the
chance to run with you and the rest of
of the uh the nfl legends and
you know um chris carter ran really well
i mean
he he he really ran
very well like he had a shot to break
five seconds just like
ironically chris is one of the guys who
was saying the whole time mike you know
what man i'm just going coast i'm not
gonna run too hard i'm gonna make sure
and as soon as he get down on that line
his competitive juices started flowing
and chris looked really good running the
run i thought ray ran well
you know i didn't know what i was gonna
get from jerry but he's the girl he's
the goatee
you know 40 won't matter with him but
guys really did put that all into it and
that was really exciting to see
michael vick here on the rich eisen show
and it's just the camaraderie
uh amongst the legends and then of
course the legends and donors but just
seeing the eight
nfl legends out there just on a field
and seeing the competitive juices get
going and then
you having an opportunity saying i
wanted to throw a pass to jerry rice and
then you did
oh man so cool that was amazing that was
so cool
like one of my coolest moments um that i
would
definitely be able to share with with my
kids and uh
you know i grew up idolizing jerry rice
i was a big time 49ers fan and
love steve young and jerry and that
whole connection and
jury to montana and you know always
follow his career you know even after
san francisco even though i was a little
distraught but at the same time always
remain that he was jerry rice fans so
thanks for making that happen too
because being in that arena
i was able to ask him jerry let me get
one and he gave me two
we only got we only got video of one but
he's it was a slant
that was a great you threw a dark mic
well actually i thought he would want to
run a go route or something right i told
him give me something that you know he
gave everybody else
you know what really worked out there he
was like a slant i'm like
bro that's so old school like that's
like the first
uh concept pass play that was put into
the west coast system
you know uh but you know he ran into
perfection still at the age of
whatever he is i won't say but man it
was really cool to throw a pass to jerry
rice
the whole thing was great and then again
the camaraderie like i said
just seeing the night before when we all
got together to talk about the event
ray and rod woodson just swapping
stories about their super bowl year
together
my favorite story though mike was the
one you told about ray
and him please please tell everyone this
story
right here on the rich eyes and show
michael vick go forward well
just in a short um you know i've
only been afraid to play against one
player in
all my years of football and that one
player was ray lewis
and every year we played against ray
when i was with the falcons or the
eagles
either ray was hurt or i was hurt every
time the ravens and
whatever team i was playing playing for
class then
um this particular day uh
2012 week two you know it was ravens
versus
eagles and and i i was i was out on the
field president and ray was present
and um you know ray was a little older
then you know i
it's like 37 years old and i think i was
32
and i just wasn't afraid no more i'm
like he
you know he not really looking the same
the physique you know but he still got
it you know he's still
ray lewis he's still he's still a
presence in
they made shady mccoy fumble and ray
picked it up
and he thought he was home sweet home he
thought he had a straight shot to the
end zone
rich and i've ran him down he see me
coming and i'm
telling when i say i super power body
slam
that was the best taco i ever made in my
life and i only got about six
i only got about six and one of them was
on ray
and when i when i tossed them i think i
threw them like six yards out of bounds
i found out a lot about myself too all
the hard work
all the hard work in the weight room
paid off
that's amazing that is so great but ray
you know it's funny
about ray you know certainly when you're
around him in an environment like this
and he's
kind of chill but you know uh having fun
and everything like that
but he did say to everybody
you know and this is the thing that i
was so happy about the run with the nfl
legends michael vick is that everyone's
like
well let's do this again we'll train
we'll do it he looked at me and he goes
you have to train too you know and i'm
like oh
i'm like i realize what what you're
talking about the intimidation factor he
like looked at me like his demeanor
changing because you know you have to
drink too
i'm like oh okay yes got it yes
the upmost respect for ray lewis and the
one thing i will say
a lot of those legends and the guys who
ran even the entrepreneurs i i just
spoke to andy dunn a couple days ago
cool everybody was like we're going to
train next year so
it's going to be a super cool event and
uh just give people more to look forward
to man and uh
definitely uh an honor to be working
alongside you rich
uh what we was able to do for saint john
well i mean we've got the names up here
you know you ran with andy dunn
uh mark laurie brett adcock jason
robbins nate foust vinnet bharara jenny
fleiss i mean
and then also um we had uh michael
robbins uh donate as well put him all
together
uh michael rubin pardon me put it all
together and and it was an incredible
haul
but when you put eight nfl legends and
eight
type a business people uh on the field
there was a certain competitive juice
flowing and then it was a day where
there's
music blaring inside of sofi stadium at
hollywood park because ram season ticket
holders were there
it felt it felt exciting and i can't
think atmosphere i
i can't thank you enough for for doing
it michael really appreciate it
and the one thing i will do in closing
yes
i will listen to my wife because she
told me
two months back if you don't train
you're going to blow out your hamstrings
and it happens she was the only person i
was thinking about when it happened i
was like man i gotta start listening to
my wife boyfriend
i love the lesson like another lesson
learned and it was a big time lesson
that came out of that so
thanks again no i feel the same way hey
michael but before i let you go i would
be remiss if i didn't ask you about
aaron rodgers and what's going on with
the packers and what you think
is going through his brain with his end
game scenario and
you know your colleague at fox sports
and terry bradshaw saying
i don't know if you're aware of this he
said today that that's it shows aaron to
be
weak that he's concerned about a kid and
jordan love i'm wondering put it all
together your two cents and what is
going on with aaron rodgers and the
packers
michael yeah well i think aaron rodgers
has the right to
to feel what he's feeling um you know
i've always been a guy when
you know backups was drafted um twice in
my career
but only to be drafted in the third
round
you know i kind of looked at it as a
threat and not not only is a
threat to me and i took it as a positive
to
to work harder and be even better it's
just
another thing that exists that you have
to deal with
you know and that's the media you know
always asking you about this guy and
always
inquiring about him and knowing that the
organization is
really leaning towards this kid at some
point in the future
which is something that we can't control
it's the inevitable
but aaron has done a lot and i think in
terms of you know how
business has been handled and may have
not always been the most accurate
who knows we're not in those rooms or
you know we're not
a part of those conversations but he has
the right to feel what he's feeling as
a quarterback and and um
it's just hard to play ball
international football league especially
quarterback
um on all levels and when you add a
bunch of different
extra pressures to that it can lead to
frustration and i think that's what
aaron's dealing with and
you know he's going to take a page out
of the tom brady book and probably
vet out the best opportunity but in the
end sometimes in the grand scheme of
things change is good
and i think aaron rodgers has a chance
to to create some change and
the green bay pike is in a great
position still you just don't have aaron
rodgers you got the guy you wanted
and you got the guy you like and jordan
love
and you still have a chance most
importantly rich i'll say this
most importantly they still have a
chance to win
the nfc north like come on i mean
you got chicago you got minnesota you
got detroit
so it's always a chance and i think
aaron rodgers left this team
you know in in a better situation than
when he started so
that's something he can hang his head on
but i look forward to seeing what
happens with him
in the future yeah because you say
change is good i i just also think that
when it comes down to it the best chance
in place for him to win is staying in
green bay
obviously but but but i mean if he's not
going to sit oddly by and wait
for the tap to come on the shoulder when
he has some sort of leverage right now
to
to get what he wants either to stay
there or get where he wants to go
now like uh you know i i i
i so i can kind of understand what he is
in fact doing
i understand and then you look at teams
like i'll just name one
look at the washington redskins i mean
they got defense they got better in the
offseason they got ron rivera
they got defense they got weapons they
got a run game
if i was earning rodgers i'll be on the
washington football team i'm sorry
excuse me
i'll be wearing the washington football
team for sure
interesting michael thanks the time
greatly appreciate it uh
and thanks again for your generosity
there your time your hamstrings and
let's do it again that was really great
as you know everybody was talking about
doing it again and making it bigger i'm
thrilled to hear that you and andy dunn
are already talking about that that's
great to hear and let's
let's let's literally figuratively run
it back let's do it let's run it back
baby
thanks michael i appreciate the time you
got it that's uh fox sports
michael vick four-time pro bowler and
4.72
runner with half a hamstring at age 40
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here